votre sentiment le rôle qu'a pu jouer
charlie hebdo dans le passage à l'acte
peut-être de certains en terroriste
alors alors attention aujourd'hui on est
on est vraiment en ligne de crête
c'est à dire que je ne veux pas je
voudrais pas mal interprété les propos
qui viennent d'être d'être tenu oui
probablement que cette cette
médiatisation cette nouvelle
réaffirmation de nos valeurs je préfère
le formuler comme ça qui a été fait
d'ailleurs au plus haut niveau de l'état
par le président de la république en
expliquant que c'est culturel c'est un
autre histoire en caricature et on avait
l'intention de continuer à le faire dans
ce sens là oui mais la guerre c'est
difficile à l'époque pour fait moi je ne
veux pas qu'on sombre dans l'esprit
munichois si vous voulez c'est à dire
qu'être pacifistes à tout prix et que 2
et de renoncer en voit des choses qu'on
a mis des siècles à construire en france
qui renonce pour ne pas déranger des
fascistes si vous voulez alors bien sûr
que déranger des fascistes et on prend
le risque de mettre en colère des
fascistes et on prend le risque d'avoir
des morts la guerre c'est pas facile
la guerre c'est par définition c'est
dangereux mais on a le choix entre la
mener ou alors se coucher et je pense
que et là pour le coup je suis ravi des
déclarations qui ont été faites par le
président de la république
on réaffirme nos valeurs ça va nous
coûter des morts probablement mais 10 à
nos soldats qui meurent aujourd'hui dans
la bande sahélienne
nous policiers sont en première ligne je
me suis sans moi je suis pas policier je
suis plutôt de culture militaire nos
policiers son niveau se trouve en
premier la leaf vous savez moi j'étais
en algérie entre 94 et 96 dans les
années noires ont donné pour pour l'état
français je dirais donc en partenariat
avec les algériens ont donné des leçons
d'humanisme aux algériens en leur disant
les droits de l'homme c'est pas bien si
les algériens nous nos amis algériens
nous avait écoutés jamais eu ne serait
sorti de cette solution de 7,2 cette
position on a fait on a affaire à des
fous si vous voulez donc on les raisons
de pas encore une fois la comparaison
avec le fascisme et est-ce qu'on peut
des fascistes et des fascistes
est-ce que ans après la guerre
kaka que quand on l'a on a fait les
procès de nuremberg on aurait envisagé
de dépolitiser des gens l'extrémiste
comme ça non on n'a pas plus de chance
de dfa chizé un fasciste que de désister
à miser un islamiste donc ça on a essayé
ça a été toutes les démarches des
radicalisations donc il faut faire la
guerre et la guerre c'est dur et ça fait
plaisir à personne de la faire et
surtout pas à ce qu'ils savent ce que
c'est mais il faut la mener ou alors on
décide d'arrêter
et puis de se coucher donc comme je vois
pas de d'issue dans ce sens là bien sûr
on nous raconte morts et encore une fois
il faut y aller rené georges querry
comment est-ce qu'on l'amène aujourd'hui
cette guerre contre le terrorisme
comment l'amener jusque là comment
est-ce qu'il faut la mener dans les
prochains mois les prochaines années
alors je voudrais revenir sur les propos
que j'ai tenus de façon à ce que les
choses soient très claires et très nette
lorsque vous m'avez demandé pourquoi il
avait un regain avec l'assassinât du
professeur il ya quinze jours et
maintenant de ces trois personnes dans
l'église
j'ai donné une explication je n'ai pas
donner une justification je m'explique
peut-être que le procès de charlie hebdo
et la résurgence du débat sur les
dessins ça a pu à nouveau susciter dans
l'esprit des petits seins des réflexes
basiques de violence avec l'idée la
recherche d' assassiner mais bien
évidemment il ne s'agit pas pour moi de
dire il faut arrêter de faire des
caricatures il faut se coucher devant
les islamistes
il ne faut pas les provoquer il faut
tout leur cd ça n'est absolument pas mon
état d'esprit ça n'est absolument pas ma
logique je suis rené sur le contexte en
fait dans dans lequel se sont déroulées
ces deux derniers faits pour revenir
alors sur la lutte antiterroriste quel
regard est ce que vous portez vous qui
est l'ancien patron de l'unité de
coordination de la lutte antiterroriste
quel est le regard que vous portez sur
ce qui est mise en oeuvre aujourd'hui il
y a tout d'abord l'engagement de la
france à l'étranger et moi aussi je
salue le travail remarquable réalisé à
la fois par les militaires par les
services secrets par tous ceux qui
risquent leur vie
en afrique au moyen-orient pour essayer
de contenir et juguler cette menace
terroriste ya quand même eu des succès
au moyen-orient puisque des châles qaïda
tout ça ça a été quand même sérieusement
déstabilisé et puis en france pareil les
services de police les services de
renseignement la dg cela dg si tout le
monde est mobilisé y compris les
gardiens de la paix dans la rue tous
ceux qui sont un titre ou un autre des
preuves dépositaire d'une prérogative de
puissance publique tous
tous sont mobilisés y compris d'ailleurs
les agents de sécurité
moi même dans mon travail de sécurité
privées et les sociétés que j'utilise
sont sensibilisés à ce risque
maintenant la détermination il existe
sur le terrain la volonté politique le
président de la république l'a réaffirmé
au lendemain de l'assassinât du
professeur d'histoire et puis gilbert
maintenant après vous avez vous avez des
individus qui échappe à la surveillance
qui passe sous les radars et il va
falloir comme le disait d'ailleurs
monsieur sa case accepter qu'il y ait
encore des morts pour lutter contre
cette menace
ce sont des loups solitaires qu'évoque
la rené georges querry un gilles sacaze
comment est-ce qu'on gère je n'aime pas
bien sûr comment dire ce terme de loup
solitaire ça donne toujours l'impression
que qu'elle s'est un peu hors sol et que
ça nous ramène plus à des schémas je
dirais de droit commun de criminalité de
droit commun donc jeu
tout dépend comment on utilise je n'aime
pas ce terme là parce que ces gens là en
fait s'inscrivent dans une stratégie de
terrorisme au low cost qui est encore
une fois on révèle rien du tout qui a
affiché depuis des années donc qui
s'inscrivent en lice hier une idéologie
qui est l'islam politique où l'islamisme
donc ce terme l'aïe peut quelquefois
induire alors pas les experts parce que
je crois que maintenant ça fait plus
débat
mais mais induire un petit peu je dirais
quelquefois la presse ou où la
population est dû à l'erreur donc donc
ce qui est difficile si vous voulez ce
qui est à la fois intéressant c'est de
noter que non plus que la capacité à
faire en mettre en place des opérations
low cost donc c'est aussi un signe
positif si vous voulez trouver quelqu'un
qui puisse en vous quasi sans logistique
va acheter un couteau et mène une
opération avec un couteau
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui ils ont du
mal à monter une opération plus
structurée avec une reconnaissance avec
avec de l'armement avec alors je dis pas
que ça n'arrivera plus attention mais
actuellement aujourd'hui on a affaire à
des attaques plutôt très low cost ce qui
veut dire qu'en face c'est très
difficile d'anticiper parce qu'on n'est
pas sur une analyse d'un goût qu'on
connaît bien avec comme on dira le chef
politique le responsable de la
logistique
le responsable des opérations sas une
approche très occidental qui est très
confortable parce que c'est ça
correspond un peu notre façon de
travailler
ça fait longtemps qu'on s'y adapter et
que le renseignement ne fonctionne plus
comme ça mais je schématise et je
caricature un peu pour vous pour que
tout le monde comprenne bien
donc c'est très difficile d'anticiper
parce que dieu c'est difficile de dire
comment s'était dit à l'instant de
d'être dans la tête des gens et savoir à
quel moment ils ont atteint un seuil de
radicalisation qui fait qu'ils vont
passer à l'acte en revanche le point
positif c'est que avec des moyens de
protection gelé somme toute assez
basique on peut un peu s'en prémunir
si vous voulez et c'est là qu'on n'ait
pas fait qu'on n'est pas bons c'est là
qu'on a encore une voie d'amélioration
à l'instant on parlait de sécurité
privée je pense que
sans aller dans le tout privé moi je
suis pas sur un modèle américain je
crois qu'il ya des choses qui doivent
rester régaliennes mais le privé
n'occupe pas toute la place qui pourrait
occuper pour compléter les polices
nationale et municipale pour être
quelquefois présent quand la police ne
peut pas être présent pour pour entraver
la démarche pour compliquer les choses
il ya l'action en elle même si vous
voulez mais il ya aussi sur les toutes
les actions qu elle ne sait pas si c'est
le cas à nice mais jusqu'à présent même
les actions les plus sommaires
elles ont pour la plupart tout fait
l'objet d'une d'une petite
reconnaissance la sécurité privée les
systèmes de vidéosurveillance etc
quand on a des gens formés là qui sont à
leur place ils ont leur rôle à jouer si
vous voulez un repérage ça se repère
donc le tout c'est que tout le monde
travaille en parfaite coordination que
les gens se fassent confiance et que
l'on fasse pas semblant qu'on ne met pas
des moyens pour se déresponsabiliser
juridiquement comme on le voit
quelquefois dans le dans le secteur
privé qu'on ait vraiment des gens qui
savent pourquoi ils sont là ce qu'ils
ont ce qu'ils doivent repérer ce qui
doivent chercher qui soit capable de ça
sans avoir peur de le faire de téléphone
à la police pour leur signaler quelque
chose que l'amu les 6-17 que les biens
et les prennent au sérieux parce qu'ils
savent ce sont des gens sérieux etc etc
on a un énorme travail à faire de
cohérence de coordination et de
continuum encore une fois parce que
c'est le terme qui était retenue en
matière de sécurité mais on est capable
de le faire le modèle israélien n'est
pas transposable partout mais on doit
s'en inspirer il ya des choses qui
fonctionnent avec nous avait sur va
juste faire un rapide point sur les
faits qui se sont donc déroulées ce
matin un peu après 9 heures dans le
centre de la ville de nice dont un
l'église notre-dame trois personnes ont
été tuées dont deux à l'intérieur de
l'édifice religieux les faits se sont
déroulés en plein coeur de la ville une
attaque au couteau l'assaillant a été
interpellé
un homme d'une trentaine d'années
interpellé par les forces de l'ordre
auquel il aurait crié à plusieurs
reprises allahou akbar selon des sources
proches de l'anc est selon également la
mairie de nice dont le premier adjoint
était sur notre antenne tout à l'heure
et puis on apprend à l'instant jean
castex qui a participé ce matin une
salle à une cellule de crise au
ministère de l'intérieur en compagnie
évidemment du chef de l'état emmanuel à
maquereau et du ministre de l'intérieur
jean castex le premier ministre déclare
porter le plan vigie par vigipirate au
niveau rouge ans attentats partout en
france rené georges querry qu'est ce que
cela signifie comment vous décrypter
cette cette annonce voilà en gros le
plan vigipirate est effectivement un
plan qui a été mis en place dans les
années 90 par pierre joxe et rocard à
matignon où on sait sont des formats de
dispositifs préventifs en fonction de
l'état de la menace
concrètement ça veut dire peut-être un
peu plus de moyens peut être mobilisé
deux militaires après c'est le premier
ministre qui décidera avec le ministre
de l'intérieur remède peut-être plus de
monde sur le terrain on est dans une
période comme ils avaient été demandés
le directeur général de la police avait
demandé aux services d'avoir une
vigilance particulière sur les églises
des cimetières en période de la
toussaint
donc l'objectif c'est d'abord et surtout
d'avoir un peu plus de moyens pour mieux
couvrir les points sensibles mais on a
bien vu par exemple pour l'action qui a
été mené contre les anciens locaux de
charlie hebdo ou deux personnes ont été
grièvement blessées
l'individu a agi sur un local qui
n'était plus occupé depuis quatre ans et
demi il a blessé deux façons collatéral
de personnes qui se trouvaient devant ce
n'était pas du tout l'objectif qu'il
s'était fixé
donc on peut toujours déployées déployer
déployés mais on ne sera jamais à l'abri
d'un d'une action délirante parce que
nous avons affaire à des gens des livres
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous diriez
des moyens qui sont alors dans la
beaucoup beaucoup entendu parler mais
mais vous qui avez donc coordonner
l'unité de la lutte antiterroriste
qu'est ce que vous diriez des moyens qui
sont déployés aujourd'hui où est-ce que
ça pêche
comment est ce qu'on peut améliorer la
lutte contre contre le terrorisme rené
georges querry alors tout d'abord sur un
plan juridique qui a rien à ajouter
la loi sur le renseignement la loi sur
le renseignement qui a été votée il ya
maintenant trois ou quatre ans au
lendemain de charlie hebdo et du
bataclan donne tous les moyens possibles
aux services de renseignement avec une
commission de contrôle qui fait son
boulot
donc ils ont les moyens juridiquement
d'agir et ils ne commettent pas de
d'excès la commission est là pour les en
empêcher si tenté que ils commettent des
excès ce qui n'est pas le cas
au plan judiciaire pareil les services
de enquête judiciaire également tous les
moyens juridiques
il n'y a rien à ajouter avec des gardes
à vue qui peuvent aller jusqu'à six
jours en cas de nécessité les services
structurellement travailler ensemble la
police judiciaire comme les services de
renseignement sont dans les mêmes locaux
se voient tous les jours ils se
connaissent ils savent faire passer un
dossier de son statut de police
administrative police des renseignements
au clan judiciaire après évidemment
c'est d'aller chercher ces individus on
a affaire à une nébuleuse qui n'est
absolument pas structuré qui n'a rien à
voir avec le terrorisme que nous avons
connu dans les années quatre-vingt six
dans les années 80 2 je pense à
l'attentât de la rue des rosiers jeu je
pense à l'attentât contre le la
synagogue
et puis 86 pareil c'était une règle
contre la fnac
on avait en face de nous des groupes qui
ai vu qui venait du moyen-orient qui
était armé qui avait une puissance de
feu assez secret d 1,95 aussi avec le
gia et l'algérie et nous avons en face
de nous des interlocuteurs avec lesquels
il était possible quand même de discuter
l'ancien patron de la dea
s'il a reconnu ya pas longtemps qu'il
avait eu des contacts avec des
terroristes du moyen-orient pour
négocier des cessez le feu si jose luis
caméra si l' on a rien en face de nous
on a on a une idéologie on a une
communauté de mauvais esprit une
communauté de méchanceté une communauté
de fanatisme et on a des gens avec
lesquels il est impossible de dialoguer
c'est pas possible non seulement parce
que il n'y a pas d'interlocuteurs qui
pourrait incarner de cette mouvance
islamiste
mais aussi parce que eux-mêmes ceux qui
sont dans la vie de tous les jours prêt
à passer à l'acte n'ont aucune logique
sinon celle de tuer et de mourir et là
c'est quand même très compliqué c'est un
constat très inquiétant que vous dressez
la rené georges querry les a pas de
solution alors contre l'a77 menaces
terroristes
on a vu le lendemain de l'assassinât de
samuel pâtit que les réseaux sociaux
pouvaient avoir un rôle néfaste donc le
débat sur la possibilité de neutraliser
les réseaux sociaux au risque d'ailleurs
de porter atteinte à la liberté de la
presse puisque le conseil
constitutionnel avait balayé le projet
de loi via qui avait été présenté il ya
quelques mois les réseaux sociaux très
bien et jouent un rôle
et puis vous avez toute cette propagande
qui est distillée et un stylet est
répandue dans certaines associations
dans certaines institutions dans
certaines mosquées un venin un venin qui
est qui se développe par capillarité
dans la communauté musulmane est moi je
pense que dans ce contexte la communauté
musulmane doit aussi faire son boulot et
doit calmer
détecter et signalé des individus dont
elle pense c'est connu que cette
communauté musulmane qu'elle fait du
tort à la communauté musulmane et que
ces individus peuvent être sont
susceptibles sinon de passer à l'acte au
moins tenir des propos inacceptables
avec derrière effectivement un possible
passage à l'acte alors on parlait tout à
l'heure du loup solitaire effectivement
c'était il ya deux ou trois ans quand il
les premières actions individuelles ont
parlé des loups solitaires moi non plus
je n'aime pas beaucoup cette expression
si ces individus agissent agisse seul
elle peut faire des dégâts
avec pas grand chose j'ouvre une triste
parenthèse mais nice est frappé pour la
deuxième fois la dernière fois c'était
avec un individu qui avec un camion il
n'avait pas d'explosifs ils n'avaient
pas d'armes à feu
fallait un petit revolver sur lui dès
qu'il n'a même pas utilisé avec un
camion
il a quand même tué 86 personnes il en a
blessé des centaines donc nice est quand
même particulièrement visés et bien
cette notion du solitaire n'existe pas
parce qu'on voit bien que lorsque on
fait des enquêtes sur ces individus qui
agissent seuls ils ne sont pas seuls en
amont ils vivent avec des gens qui ne
peuvent pas ignorer qu'il côtoie des
individus qui sont fanatisés et donc il
devrait pouvoir penser et détecter
qu'ils sont capables à un moment ou un
autre de passer à l'acte et devrait les
signaler aux services de renseignements
aux services de police pour mieux faire
le travail pour les mieux cibler ce
potentiel de haine et violence
rené georges querry vous restez avec
nous un tout dernier mois avec vous
gilles sacaze ancien cadre de la dgse je
vous libère juste après mais rarement
aussi sur le contexte géopolitique avec
notamment la russie la turquie pardon le
président turc erdogan qui tient à ces
derniers jours ces derniers sept
dernières semaines ces derniers mois des
propos très virulents à l'égard d'
emmanuel macron et donc de la france
or on l'a rappelé et ses manifestations
qui ont lieu ces dernières
derniers jours contre les propos qu'il a
tenus pour la liberté d'expression pour
le droit de caricaturer est ce que cette
ambiance en dehors de la france peut
jouer un rôle quelconque dans ce que mon
traversons aujourd'hui
alors tout d'abord si vous permettez je
voudrais m'excuser auprès de monsieur
kerry de d'avoir fait un début de
mauvaise interprétation de ses propos je
vois connais parfaitement en phase donc
pour répondre à votre question oui bien
sûr de la même manière que les
caricatures ou notre contexte intérieur
influence la menace le passage à l'acte
c'est les déclarations récentes
d'erdogan n'apaise pas les choses c'est
évident maintenant erdogan se permet ça
parce qu'il sent bien que l'europe est
divisée que quand on est un peu fébrile
sur nos appuis
même s'il semblerait qu encore une fois
ça change un peu et qu'on réaffirmons un
certain nombre de choses et il sent il
s'engouffre dans la brèche je veux dire
c'est ilafy erdogan ne fait zéro
déclarations enflammées contre la chine
qui pourtant est en train de quasi de
mener 7 génocide est en tout cas de
malmener les ouigours donc ça ça de ça
le gêne pas je dirigeais pas de
déclaration de la ligue est accueilli
depuis votre d'autres exemples comme ça
si on y regarde de près
moi je crois que la france puisqu'on est
sur la dimension un peu politique
internationale je crois que la france
n'est forte finalement que quand elle
réaffirme ses valeurs pas quand elle
s'aligne derrière les américains
derrière les russes où je vous dise un
peu pas convocation mais quand on choisi
de s'aligner derrière quelqu'un on
disparaît puisque finalement on n'a plus
besoin de discuter avec nous donc on est
forte quand on réaffirme nos valeurs
qu'on me semble-t-il
on est en train de le faire la preuve
c'est que le danemark je crois que c'est
hier le danemark c'est c'est cette
affiche et solidaire par rapport au
théâtre qu'à tueur à la france
donc voilà on est un peu les porter le
fer de lance des valeurs universelles
réaffirmant sa et faisons face faisant
face à ces pas facile et ça fait rêver
personne mais on n'a pas d'autre choix
que de se battre ou de ou alors de de
changer complètement notre société rené
georges querry
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ce qu'on
vient d'entendre dans la bouche de 10 à
15 je compléterai tout d'abord en
rappelant qu'il ya quelques années alors
j'arrive pas à le situer dans le temps
quelques personnes mais franchement
complètement délirante on imaginer que
la turquie faisait partie de l'europe et
on imaginer que la turquie puisse
rentrer dans l'union européenne
à l'époque je me demandais si c'était
une farce ou si il avait fumé la
moquette
on voit bien aujourd'hui que la turquie
n'a rien à voir mais strictement rien à
voir avec l'europe
né au plan historique né au plan
culturel ni au plan économique après une
fois qu'on a dit ça
il est clair que le dirigeant qu'ils ont
aujourd'hui et qui n'a rien à voir
évidemment avec le fondateur de la de
lavery turquie laïque est un type qui
souffle sur les braises qui réanime et
entretient un islamisme anti-européen et
tous ces discours tous ces comportements
qui sont diffusées dans le monde entier
sont bien évidemment de nature à
aggraver à réanimer a réactivé le
radicalisme mesure mais ce contexte
géopolitique rené georges querry lorsque
vous vous cordonnier la lutte
antiterroriste comment est ce qu'elle se
répercuter dans ce combat au quotidien
leleu
quand vous avez en face de vous des
groupes terroristes dont vous savez
qu'ils revendiquent une idée politique
une cct valable d'ailleurs pour le
terrorisme interne en france action
directe avec son idéologie d'extrême
gauche
les corses avec le souci d'avoir
l'indépendance les basques etc
on arrive à un moment ou un autre au
delà de la riposte policière et
judiciaire a trouvé discussions des
terrains d'entente même si avec les
corses
ça a duré longtemps parce qu'il
respectait pas souvent leurs engagements
mais à la fin on arrive à trouver une
solution c'était pareil avec le
terrorisme et moyen-orientales dans les
années quatre-vingt six n'a subi une
vingtaine d'attentats en france un peu
partout on veut ramener là dessus mais
on savait que derrière
chiite libanais et on a pu outre en
complément de la riposte policière
en démantelant un réseau qui étaient les
eaux fouad ali salah ce qui a mis un
terme aux attentes à 2 mandats puis
aussi allez expliquer à ceux qui est au
moyen-orient au liban qu'il fallait
qu'ils à rennes parce que vous pouvez y
avoir une riposte militaire il pouvait y
avoir une riposte peut-être d'ailleurs
at elle eu lieu dans la plus grande des
discrétions je n'en sais rien je tu vas
dans le secret des dieux mais les
services de la dgse sont également là
les services spéciaux pour les forces
spéciales pour justement expliqué à ces
gens là qu'il faut arrêter parfois
souvent même ça a du sens et ça
d'efficacité aujourd'hui encore une fois
on n'a rien on est dans une espèce de
nébuleuse où nous n'avons aucun
interlocuteur avec lequel on pourrait
discuter pour essayer de mettre un terme
à ces actions violentes qui sont chaque
fois le fait d' illuminé de fanatiques
d'individus qui ne connaissent que la
violence la haine la haine est de même
d'ailleurs finalement parce que à la fin
ils ont envie de mourir et l'âge je le
redis ça va être très long et très
compliqué et